just one thing you find when you go in
and you would have found this when you
went into the Kingstown like it's
insanely resonant right it's just the
Acoustics in there are off the charts
that's not very underwhelming which
makes me feel like it wasn't a chamber
the awe-inspiring view of the pyramids
on the outside and then you get into
this Kings chamber right yeah it's a box
it's a box so this is made up of like 70
ton Granite monolith there's no question
the feet in order to execute placing
these 70-ton Granite blocks around it
it's very special when you look at the
grandiosity of like the dynasty
Egyptians you're right it's not
reflected in this room in any way and if
that was the King's Room like for a king
that I think would be a little different
it makes way more sense to me that this
is a power Factory because if I'm the
king and that's the room you made me
you're dead do we know